What's in the box?
What's in this box that I so perfectly wrapped?
This is a gift for you.
For me?
This is a company that I work with,
their factory is in Addis Ababa, in Ethiopia
which is my favorite place in the world,
my daughter was born there.
Really?
Yeah.
And I just got choked up saying that and yes.
And she cries on TV, okay.
There's still space, room for that.
Sex trafficking has exploded in Ethiopian.
One of the largest Open air markets is in Addis Ababa
and women, young girls get off the bus every day
and they're being auctioned off within, you know an hour
and a friend of mine and his wife started a company
called Parker and Clay and it's just ironic
that it's called Parker and Clay
but we became really close
and we actually have traveled to Ethiopia together.
And they have adopted children from Ethiopia as well.
And they make the most beautiful products.
They employ 80% women.
They've taken so many women from the street
and I've visited the red light district in Addis
and it's pretty harsh.
So, so many of the profits go, but they also stay,
they live there, they work with the people,
fair wage, they get lunch.
It's a beautiful factory.
I've been to the factory and it look what it has on it.
(Drew squealing)
(audience clapping)
Yeah and it's, this I like to think of as like,
a picnic bag, because you can put a water bottle in it
and the other side you can put like little snacks and food.
And then this one is just like a beautiful tote.
That, and it's, yeah.
(audience clapping)
Mary-Louise.
Surprise,
so good to see you. Give me a hug.
Anything else you want from there,
anything, I'll get it for you.
This is so incredibly me.
And you can catch Mary-Louise in "How I learned to Drive"
on Broadway now, 25 years from when you-
I'm supporting Broadway, yeah.
And David Morris first did it.
That is so real.
I'm trying to revive Broadway, it's so important to me.
I'm going, I'm in.
It's an hour and a half, no intermission.
Oh, I love it.
Easy.
And this is just so thoughtful and beautiful.
I cannot wait to support it in life and carry you with me.
I love that so much.
As well as this deep and meaningful thing.
Thank you guys so much.
(upbeat music)